debout qu'est ce qui t'a alim
attachez votre ceinture redresser votre
siège en jeu votre tablette
parce que nous allons pas tardé avec
ralph te plaît pour une fois est ce que
tu peux plus clair on va dans l'internet
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs bienvenue sur un
carnage
[Musique]
hu
waouh cool
regarde moi tous ces machins les plus
beaux miracle j'ai jamais vu de toute ma
vie
bienvenue au bar de recherche que puis
je vous aide à trouver aujourd'hui bain
moussant pains de minuit bain de foule
noms de villes noms de pays non
d'athlètes classique arbalète artichauts
j'ai comme l'impression qu'il essaie de
deviner ce que tu vas dire m'a saisie
automatique est un peu nerveuse ces
jours ci attend l'est trouvez moi un
site internet qui déchire bien des
livres aux jeunes et qu'un seul résultat
non dispensés du personnage de dessin
animé
qui va le cuir
[Musique]
salies on se calme et puis je suis une
princesse choisi et quel genre de prince
se situe qu'à chevelure est magique non
des mains sont magiques
non tu parti avec les animaux non
contente toi de zénon ensorcelé n'ont
enlevé séquestré et vous êtes sûr que ça
va ou faut que j'appelle la police
est ce que les gens pensent que tous tes
problèmes se sont réglés parce qu'un
homme fort et puissant a surgi dans ta
vie ouais mais quand ça se fait
d'ailleurs
[Musique]